Let's see who else we've got holding.
Let's try our caller from the.
Eight four five area code.
Who's calling today from eight four five.
I think that's me.
You doing, David?
It is a Cadillac.
David Cadillac.
I like it.
All right.
Yes.
I have a question for you.
Speaking to take in higher ground, I got a
bit of an anger problem most of my life and
I got it under control.
But now he's with all these ignorant people,
you know, walking around without wearing their
masks and, you know, the regular moronic things
we see as normal people.
I feel myself coming back to the person I
used to be in trying to avoid it because I'm
so angry, these idiots.
I don't know what to do about it.
And speaking of taking higher ground, I really
appreciated your interview with that Jesse
Lee Peterson guy in my day.
It was so entertaining that I just wanted
to call and say thanks for living everything
up a little bit.
I needed it.
Well, I appreciate that.
Now, are you aware?
I don't know if I hear, like, a New Yorker
or maybe a Philly accent there.
Where are you located that you're dealing
with these these morons so often?
The town I'm in is actually Chester, New York.
I worked in Manhattan all my life, so I'm
only a half hour away, OK?
We've seen the devastation here.
So when you're saying you're getting mad at
people, is it are you getting in verbal confrontations?
Is it escalating to physical?
Oh, he hasn't gotten physically yet, but they
are.
No.
I used to be the person who would agitate
the fight.
Now his it seems like someone nicely and they
want to agitate a fight.
So I you know, I've done the right thing.
I learned my life lessons.
I walk away.
But at the same time.
I don't know how people deal with these.
I just don't know it's not easy to ignore.
But what is it sort of like you ask someone
to put a mask on and they lose their mind
or what's going on?
Lose their minds like literally like crazy
people.
I compared them to children, really because
they lose a toddler is what it seems like,
but they lose their minds.
Police, too.
I got in a confrontation with a cop last week
because he was in a store getting his coffee
next to me.
Is a buddy.
I think you might want to put a mask on.
We're in a gas station and he lost his mind.
I had to leave because I thought he would
just leave and arrest me or something else.
Really?
So police are.
What town was that?
That police officers aren't wearing masks
indoors?
I thought the entire state of New York had
had a pretty clear mandate on that.
I know where we say it all the time.
But there a line that you can report.
People here in New York and you know, it doesn't
do a lot of good, but at least it's a step.
Listen, here's what I would say, because I
understand I hear the frustration and I would
understand it with the way I might try to
resist the escalations would be, you know
what?
This is such a bigger problem than this one
guy or gal that even if I go completely crazy
and change their mind, it's not actually I
can't possibly do that with everybody.
And so it's a sad realization.
But I would take a more resigned view that
really the change in people's attitudes needs
to be systemic and that you can't shout everybody
into submission.
And I would approach it that way to try to
not get to, you know, hot behind the ears,
so to speak.
Yeah, no, that's absolutely dead on.
You know, we just have to keep trying to calmly
as we all can, and hopefully change some minds.
Exactly.
And hopefully before we know it, there will
be a vaccine.
Figure it out.
Yeah.
All right, my friend.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Great to hear from you, Dave Cadillac from
Chester, New York there.
OK.
Let's go next to our caller from the seven
two zero area code.
Caller, where are you?
What's your name?
Where are calling from?
Isn't it?
Yeah, it is.
I'm Aram Conn from Utah, actually interesting.
I had a question regarding the election coming
up.
You've talked at length about how you don't
think really the election appearances can
be too bad and how the how he'll just leave.
And no matter if he loses, he isn't the president.
Well, hold on a second.
Let me then it looks.
Can can we pause on.
Can we pause just for a second there.
Hello.
I want to make sure we're not mystate.
So I've not said I don't think the election
interference will be significant.
What I've said is experts who have looked
at what Trump is planning believe that each
of his little tactics will only have a modest
impact and it could flip the election to him.
But if we get the turnout up, the turnout
will do far more than any of Trump's tactics
can do that.
So it wasn't it's not that it's not going
to be significant.
It's that we know how to fight it, which is
by overwhelming the vote.
And yes, I have said I believe if Trump loses,
he will go.
Eventually, it may be under protest, but he
will go.
Right.
I was in Mark asking Mike, do you think that
anything like the 2000s Florida recount type
stuff could happen again?
Yes.
And that's where it sort of even though we
turn out, it doesn't work.
Absolutely.
And this is why I've said when we now, you
know, thinking back now, when we look at Trump's
Supreme Court picks, his judgeships, the fact
that he's now starting to file lawsuits against
vote by mail, we need to run the score up.
We need this to be like an overwhelming win
for Joe Biden, because the closer it is within
states or the closer it is from the popular
vote standpoint, it could provide cover for
judges to do very, very bad things.
And if the results are very lopsided, it just
makes it more difficult for a court as an
example to hand any state, any vote, anything
to Donald Trump.
And that's why I think it's so important that
we have the biggest possible margin in November.
We can't just win by a little bit.
We actually need to destroy Trump.
I agree.
I just want to see your trip.
Thanks for your call.
All right.
Appreciate it.
Thank you for the call.
Let's take a quick break.
If you are holding, please don't hang up,
because after what is going to feel like just
an incredibly short break, I'm going to go
right back to the phones.